The joe rogan experience.
I love dogs too.
I love animals and this,
that's something that people have a weird problem with,
but they don't have a weird problem with loving animals and then feeding their
animals.
Animals.
Like I have friends who fucking are vegans and they have cats and I'm like,
do you under fucking stand that cats only eat meat like a dog?
A dog can eat carrots,
a dog can eat grains.
Got dogs eat rice.
Like I have a friend who cooks for his dog and he gets his dog ground beef and
mixes it with potatoes and rice and it's delicious.
You do that for your dog.
Oh cool.
It's doesn't eight probably herself,
but,
but you can't do that with a cat if you can do with the cat.
It has to be just animal protein.
That's it.
That's really the only thing that cat is allowed to eat.
Yeah.
You can't feed cats grains.
Cats are not supposed to eat the rice that's supposed to eat carrots.
Catsi fish and they eat chicken and the beef and the liver and they eat.
They eat animal protein,
they're carnivores.
They're straight carnivores.
So for you to be a Vegan and have a fucking cat living in your house,
like you're involved in the killing of animals,
whether you like it or not.
I mean,
I guess there's probably some Vegan cat food,
but I can't imagine it.
Let's go kill it right now.
Probably kill the cat.
It's probably not good.
Vegan cat food bad.
Let's,
let's look up that cash.
Where the Dylan?
Yeah,
fast.
That's one of my two five days cats.
Okay.
Vegan cat food.
You know,
I just went up.
Imagine that shit is not good.
That basically mini lines.
Oh look it.
He says actually,
and the Vegan cat foods contained adequate amounts.
Is it okay to raise a cat vegan?
I think it's hilarious.
Fellow.
Other thing that is bugging Alaris now artists into activists with more than one
field on the family in Ithaca,
New York.
More in her partner.
Shariah Golding.
That means our lives.
Friends.
What a surprise.
Lesbian vegans with cats,
that's crazy.
You never hear about that.
Relatively small,
but deeply dedicated group of Vegan pet owners who believe their cats and dogs
dies.
She reflect their own beliefs.
About the treatment of animals and the environmentally sustainable,
sustainable lifestyles.
Is it okay to give your diet of spare me all the Foa,
outrage,
outrage of the billions of land,
animals and trillions of sea animals tortured and killed each year in the u s
alone for food to feed people and pets?
I don't know man.
You know,
you leave a cat outside that cat's gonna kill a bird.
That,
that's sweet kitty cat that you have as a murderer.
Yeah,
my cat makes these crazy noises.
When he looks outside,
he sees like something like a squirrel.
His whole jaw starts.
He starts,
their jaws start moving up and down.
Like they can't help it if they're just thinking about biting.
I it.
If you've had fight dreams,
like what you wake up kicking,
you know,
you know those dreams.
Well,
cats have those when they see a fucking animal that they want to kill because
it's like that.
They have reflex.
I had cats,
they make noises
so it looks out the window.
Have you ever watched them like stalk the stalk?
You stuck your leg and then watch a lion?
There is very little difference.
You're like a lion crawling through the grass or a cat roll in three a carpet.
Yeah.
Like they look identical.
Oh yeah.
Absolutely identical.
They're murderers,
bro.
They have fucking murderers apparently.
Um,
what they're saying is for a lot of these,
a lot of these people that are there making these,
uh,
these diets for these dogs,
there's like a big debate whether or not it's healthy for the dogs.
It's about the Vegas.
Yeah.
You can die.
It's for,
for dogs and cats,
whether or not it's a matter of,
uh,
the animal getting all the proper nutrients or just being able to stay alive.
So I don't really understand people's relationships with dogs in that sense.
Like I get the whole,
like men having a dog,
but as people get weird,
like we have,
we know a,
um,
a friend of a friend who told us to have a patient who's got munch houses,
you know which houses?
Yeah.
Basically.
So they basically make up things so that you can get their dog operated on.
Like it's just like as an problem so that they have an excuse to get an
operation on the door,
right?
Like it's like the kid
get away.
Apparently what they're saying is that dogs and cats have a much different
nutritional requirement and human beings and that the,
uh,
they need much higher protein intake than a human does.
So especially dogs can eat a bunch of other shit like yams and potatoes and all
these different things and it's okay as long as they get sufficient amount of
protein,
but it's almost impossible to get the amount of protein that a dog needs with
just plants and cats to fucking joke.
Cancer,
you know,
here's what,
put,
put layouts of fucking meat and lay out a bowl of beans.
See where fluffy goes.
Oh,
fluffy.
No,
you're not a murderer.
Fluffy.
The just choking down these pieces of meat,
you know,
have the yams fluffy fucking ridiculous
cat food.
Shut the fuck up.
That thing's a murderer,
man.
You're going to keep it.
Keep it from being a murderer.
It's,
it's nature.
I mean,
you know,
it's what it does.
That's what the cat does.
It's kind of comedy,
like everybody who's been pushing all the,
like the Tofu and all the soy stuff over the last couple of years,
it started to get breast cancer in men.
It's just,
they're discovering it's bad for you.
I say that stuff instead of milk and I'd always feel sick,
but I was like,
it's gotta be healthy feed.
Everyone keeps telling me that.
That's why I have boobs.
Yeah.
Even vegan cats.com is telling people to feed their cats meet.
That's when shit gets real.
When Vegan cats.com tells people to feed their cats,
meet after much soul searching,
we've decided that we need to keep our cats.
We only feed them asshole
cows.
Okay.